the time has come for me to review your
submissions yet again what are they
gonna disappoint me with this time it's
what I think every time
oh no original content maybe that's it
oh it's been looking a little weird
maybe that's it last week I asked you
bros sisters family to make something in
real life
IRL yes it exists now already scrolled
through and it looks like most of you
failed so good job good job for that
good job you did it you really did a
good job good job now let's look at him
anyway
this is my mental age 12 years let's
just start with this one
sister face dude okay so someone
actually did it a cute little it's like
the Ruby brofist that I promised that I
would give out and I didn't loose I did
not lose them at all I still have them
very kept very safely and I still have
them okay hey don't worry about it but
someone just made one that's awesome
it's not the real thing but you know you
try origami pewdiepie what no way oh
that's awesome
what you see the whole process this
better not be a troll I swear to God if
this is true
[Music]
what yes it's amazing
all right suck it that's so awesome I
love it that's so cool I thought it was
a troll i legit thought it was a troll
that's so cool
so yeah I want to try and make it
you have the tutorial that's so cool
thank you very much PewDiePie the
hypebeast
pretty much yep they're all very
different but the very first one I ever
tasted was Malcolm a 12 year old 12 euro
I get it
very nice very nice
this is all gonna be about the whiskey
video Jesus I've seen this one better
but that was really great it's really
brave of her spreading their requests
slash squad fam in the real world
respect this one took bravery this one
took artistic skill hey what is this 3d
Puetz yes that is lucky you made my
beard completely unsymmetric as well
appreciate that it is not by the way it
is not unsymmetric I trim it very nicely
it's so cool though I love it why is my
armed so looking like that's awesome
thank you very much the life of Chava
very cool what
hello rata people's go through it what
you did it oh that's so cool so she did
a t-shirt design of my old background
when I actually had effort into my
background it's really cool I'm glad you
guys actually did I thought it would all
be memes I thought it would all be memes
you have to start by believing in
yourself
mark fischbach I do everything that I do
for the fans and it means so much to me
Logan Paul you gotta want it no one else
is gonna want it for you Jake Paul I
like that one
her he's probably thinking about other
girls him it's never god damn it that
[ __ ] meme I swear to God I found this
and thought appeared oh okay well they
spelled women wrong so I don't know
that's just kind of embarrassing no
[ __ ] way
no way
[Music]
[Laughter]
what the gasps say bellissima
Wow it's a beautiful look at it you
really captured the excellence of Nick
Crompton just like I did you really
understand the soul that went into the
artwork my card I'm crying it it's
beautiful I love this
well done Rob's 2017 that's [ __ ]
awesome dad damn it the human eye can
expand up to fifty five percent when
looking at something that you love I
never seen this mean before that's
pretty original
[Music]
it got copyrighted god [ __ ] damn it I
couldn't afford original content this
year so I got you cleanbid instead a
current [ __ ] dad is so cute what the Oh
wha
ah waiter your steaks are very rare bow
that's rare recent okay [ __ ] you god
dammit mervich oh hey look at this
sculpture you really captured the beauty
of Marcia my god look at those legs
look at those legs on Marcia hell yeah
oh yeah if only if only they look like
that in real life Oh what I didn't say
anything
Wow Wow I look straight up it looks just
like me
Wow to be honest this is really cute
really cool appreciate you a AMD md5 one
get a normal name next time that's cool
that's really dub dude whoa what a
beautiful sculpture my god oh my Miyoko
new care wow you really captured my soul
my elegance my nose and my eyes wow it
looks so good it looks so good you
really did a good job this is going to
be worth a lot one day I want you to
lock this up put it in a bank or
something make sure no one touches it
because my god oh my that is incredible
Wow sister Pfister
[Music]
good job you know what I'm really tired
of this meme but you you wrapped it up
quite nicely I gotta say well done when
you become an alcoholic because of lack
of YouTube revenue the irony is that I
didn't think this video get would get
monetized I even asked YouTube and they
were like yeah probably nine and it got
monetize just fine it's the easiest one
today I just should just keep drinking
it's like YouTube is like just keep
drinking buddy you're fine
this game is hard needle felted you how
do you even do that that's awesome I
like you got my hairline as well it's so
cute
thank you very much Sean wants to die
okay okay here we go
birch and OH what that is so cool
looks beautiful a very nice dis look
like a beautiful piece of art the way
you cut it out
astonishing that's cool that I would
actually like like that one of those
that's cool appreciate you well I guess
we're twins how about that my long-lost
my long-lost twin brother mega Evan
McGregor here is Evan McGregor here I
took over for Papa this is how I talk
I'm ever macquaire for Ken a [ __ ] name
ago here
Oh notice how I talk about McGregor more
[ __ ] could go has more but my lace go
check my knees and switch your hair with
a ball pretty accurate good job
watch me cover chop suey watch me drink
my
and they said Felix was out of ideas all
right so what should we do for next week
what should the next challenge be for
you my squad fam let me know what you
should what challenge you wanted to do
next time actually you know what I think
I just got an idea make a thumbnail for
this next week's video that's all you
have to do just make a thumbnail I just
got this completely original idea out of
nowhere Wow okay yeah that's a good idea
that I just came up with me squad fam
thank you so much for watching squad fam
appreciate you guys and love your what
you do
squad fam thanks for all the submissions
as always I really really appreciate it
I think my favorite one has to be Nick
Crompton anyway love you guys thank you
so much squad fam